into the globe let's now go to
California where sal khan is using
YouTube in a way that might just blow up
the classroom we're trying to educate
the world tutoring millions online
that's what's cool about an equation you
can always check to see if you got the
right answer right now we're getting two
to three hundred thousand video views a
day we can claim to be the largest
university in the world more than 2,400
lessons and counted on everything from
basic addition a plus 1 is equal to 92
quadratic formulas negative 1 times 2 is
minus 2 photosynthesis it needs carbon
dioxide to US history we've had enough
of you great britain we are now
declaring ourselves as an independent
country any subject just search and
click all be more than 76 million times
they can pause repeat rewind without
feeling like they're wasting my time
without feeling embarrassed because
maybe they weren't paying attention the
first time or maybe they forgot
something from last year or last week
and now it's kind of in a distressed
environment it's a long way from where
it all began a friend said hey you know
why don't you put some of your lectures
on youtube and i said no that'sthat's
for dogs on skateboards that's not for
for serious mathematics and yet that was
a light bulb moment for you I gave it a
shot it's now called Khan Academy what
Saul Khan has done is amazing he's been
called Bill Gates's favorite teacher
because gates his own sons were logging
on to Khan's lessons so I see saucon as
a pioneer it's the start of a revolution
the Gates Foundation gave him one and a
half million dollars Google tossed in
two million enough to hire a small staff
and translate his lessons into 10
languages it was just a constant we
would be able to use the power
do that now is the only instructor and
he knows what he's talking about the MIT
and Harvard grad got three degrees
simultaneously in mouth electrical
engineering and computer science but
South has a dirty little secret Sal Khan
one of the best teachers in the world
hated school I it didn't register with
me I i would go to class half the time i
was bored half the time i was lost i had
i had trouble paying attention for 60
minutes which may be why south is an
education revolutionary everything i've
listed is true of both 401ks and
traditional IRAs you can make a lot of
money off of your brain but you're
giving it away for free hopefully on my
deathbed and hopefully that's not for us
many decades in the 100 years 100 years
from now obviously there's a billion
kids who learn from those lectures are
five million kids so we have a little
surprise for you we connected Sal with
just one of his millions of fans jasper
is a medical student in the netherlands
oh yeah who has spent a lot of time with
you and you just don't know it no i
watch some videos and nobody right and i
really help to understand what i have
good that's awesome yeah see i could
sleep and help teach people the crimes
like i should say one person can produce
something on their own without any extra
resources almost as a hobby and you can
reach billions of people it's a place to
be
and small whether your storm chasing
fomenting revolution or just trying to
learn biology it's a world naked